bien ya casi está ahora lo que haremos
será cambiar nuestros leds los leds son
nuestros ojos y estos leds se iluminan y
para hacerlo vamos a usar el otro
interruptor deslizable de un polo y dos
posiciones vamos a tomar nuestras piezas
de punta para hacer un pequeño bucle en
este bucle lo voy a hacer en el cable
blanco que dejamos pendiente en los
vídeos pasados y lo vamos a enlazar a
uno de los contactos restantes de
nuestro interruptor de un polo y dos
posiciones es un poco difícil así que
asegúrate de obtener un bucle muy
apretado lo pasas alrededor del contacto
y una vez que lo tengas ahí puedes tomar
tus pizzas de punta y asegurarte de que
está bien prensado contra la terminal
expuesta del interruptor debes estar
seguro de que no está tocando en ninguna
otra terminal y si lo está entonces lo
que pasará es que el interruptor siempre
estará encendido y no funcionará
adecuadamente sólo estoy torciendo
fuertemente para asegurar que está
conectado de manera firme
ahora lo que necesitamos hacer es
conectar otro cable a la soldadura de
las resistencias de nuestros leds que
hicimos en vídeos anteriores voy a
seguir adelante y doblar en esta otra
terminal del interruptor fuera del
camino que no necesitamos es decir la
terminal que está en el lado opuesto del
interruptor deslizable ok ahora tenemos
el cable de la batería el cual es el
cable negativo y lo vamos a conectar de
vuelta a las resistencias y para eso
usaremos de nuevo el cable blanco y
vamos a pelar una pequeña parte de este
cable blanco y vamos a quitarle cerca de
no sé un cuarto de pulgada de ambos
lados aunque también tres octavos de
pulgada funcionaría de manera general si
hablamos de quitar un poco más de
aislante eso es un poco más fácil porque
tienes más cable para poder enroscar
pero ten cuidado
eso significa que tendrás más cable que
cubrir una vez que hayas terminado es un
poco engañoso 10 por eso que para mí un
cuarto de pulgada funciona bastante bien
en cualquier caso puedo
el pelador de cable y jalar el cable y
si lo veníamos un poco saldrá y quedará
pelado el cable de nuevo tomaremos
nuestras pinzas de punta y vamos a
doblar esto y vamos a crear un bucle que
irá allí en la terminal
una vez que tengamos el bucle usaremos
las pizzas de punta para apretarlo en su
lugar
bien una vez que ya lo apretamos en su
lugar le podemos colocar silicón
caliente y bueno una de las cosas que
debí de haber hecho antes de colocar el
silicón caliente es probar que en efecto
los contactos estuvieran bien conectados
pero estoy muy seguro de que lo
estuvieron así que voy a seguir
colocando el silicón caliente por las
zonas de tiempo pero cuando hagan esto
va a tener que probar el interruptor y
pueden usar los leds de allí para
asegurarse que todo está propiamente
conectado antes de colocar el silicón
caliente ya que si no lo haces va a ser
más que un dolor de cabeza quitar de
nuevo el pegamento caliente y volver a
hacer todo bien ahora vamos a conectar
nuestros leds al cable restante que
tenemos en el interruptor y eso nos
permitirá completar el circuito y
encender los ojos de nuestro robot
podemos tomar los dos cables de nuestras
resistencias ponerlos en contacto y
asegurarnos de que la energía está
fluyendo como debería
pueden ver que el interruptor nos
permite encenderlo y apagarlo vamos a
torcer juntos estos cables de las
resistencias y después vamos a
envolverlos alrededor de la parte
expuesta del cable blanco y eso nos
permitirá completar el circuito y
encender las luces leds o los ojos de
nuestro robot
y una vez que los ojos han sido
conectados los cables se tuercen juntos
me voy a asegurar de que están muy bien
torcidos vamos a asegurarnos de que los
cables expuestos están separados para
que no hagan cortocircuito y ahora si
después vamos a encender y apagar el
interruptor para ver si nuestros ojos se
iluminan y de hecho lo hacen cortaremos
un pedazo de la cinta de aislar cerca de
media pulgada cuadrada y vamos a usar
esa cinta de aislar básicamente para
cubrir los cables expuestos que torcimos
juntos y con esto vamos a asegurar que
permanezcan conectados y además estén
aislados